the Middle East has had its fair share
of brutal dictators and their palaces
now it's got a new one tyrant tells the
story of a dictators second son Barry
reluctantly drawn to the family business
away from his suburban life in America
jennifer finnigan plays Barry's wife
Molly she's been married to her husband
for almost 20 years actually she thought
she knew him and there was just one
giant piece missing for her she has
never known that life that her husband
led before she met him the way he grew
up in the Middle East the way that he
was the son of basically a tyrannical
leader of this Middle Eastern country
it's a lavish production with 300 crew
and reported costs of over three million
dollars in episode some scenes like the
war room look like they've been plucked
from newsreel of Saddam Hussein or
Syria's Assad walking around the set of
tyrant you really do feel as if you've
been transported to the presidential
palace of a Middle Eastern dictator
instead of actually being just ten miles
north of tel aviv it's not the first
time us drama has come to israel
homeland filmed its Beirut scenes here
as seen in this clip it using Israel as
a stand-in for an Arab nation has been
controversial not least for Israeli Arab
actor ashraf barhom who plays berries
unhinged older brother Jamal it is
tricky but so far i believe we managed
to find really a path it's always on the
edge but I love them it goes to a
different place where it make it again
reflect about the big idea of tyranny
and ant control and you know so yeah it
is sensitive and it is challenging the
same time dictators are often depicted
as brutal and inhuman we never get to
see their softer side their
vulnerabilities tyrant could change that
during for dictators or the sopranos did
for the Mafia elliot got can Bloomberg
far Sabah Israel